what up space fam golson here from anime
upper to discuss the absolutely insane
spoilers for chapter 1044 of one piece
this is looking like it's going to be
the biggest chapter ever and that's not
an over exaggeration so make sure to
stay tuned for this one if you do enjoy
one piece of videos like this i want to
keep them coming you know what to do
channel piraking within and smash that
like button with no mercy remember
smashing that like button is parking
energy and passing is scared of rochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my big and growing
one-piece playlist that includes videos
on all the yonko warlords supernova
admirals and much more linked to that is
in the description and now without
further ado let's jump into its spoilers
and all so we left off in chapter 1043
with kaido having hit a helpless luffy
who'd just been distracted by the cp-0
agent the attack was point blank range
and luffy was already at his limit it
seemed like he was dead as if to confirm
this fact momo couldn't hear his voice
anymore kaido declared him dead and law
said luffy's voice had vanished too
kairo is skilled enough to be able to
tell on his own if luffy is dead but
having momo and law sends of 2 suggest
that luffy really did die temporarily at
least and that's why kaido king of the
beasts was declared the winner against
straw hat luffy by the narrator luffy is
not going to be the one who beats kaido
at least that luffy isn't it's going to
be the next evolution of him whether you
call that joy boy or son god luffy or
whatever we really don't have to wait
long though to find out that luffy is
not dead for good in fact we don't even
have to wait until the next chapter we
knew he wouldn't be dead since he's the
protagonist but oda could have chosen to
leave him dead for chapter 1043 and then
resolve it in chapter 1044 but oda chose
to give us something way bigger on the
last page of chapter 1043 we have
zunisha say it hears the drums of
liberation for the first time in 800
years he is here momo asks who is and
zunisha says joyboy has returned then in
the final panel it shows luffy smiling
steam coming off of him and the upper
part of his head melting the has
returned dialogue is transposed onto
this image of luffy letting us know that
as i've been saying for a long time in
the chapter reviews luffy is in fact the
joy boy of the new era last time i read
the spoilers which mentioned that the
grin was spelled as nica making the
connection to sun god nikka at the same
time but as i read the official
translation on viz just now it just says
grin with no further explanation so goes
to show how much can be lost in
translation from the japanese to the
official english translation even if it
is considered the official one but that
was the end of 1043 which many in the
community called the biggest thing that
ever happened in one piece there's been
talks since of luffy's awakening of gear
5 of what kind of fruit he actually has
of whether joy boy would be taking over
luffy's body and so on and pretty much
all of this seems to be answering the
spoilers for 1044 which is just so much
that i didn't expect to happen in this
one chapter but i'm very thankful it has
now these are spoilers and not the
directly translated pages they usually
come out on friday so take everything
with a grain of salt a lot of people
believe these are legit but there is no
100 certainty with these things so just
keep that in mind i found these
translations via oro japan 1. this
chapter is called liberation warrior
which plays off of what zunisha
mentioned last chapter namely that he
heard the drums of liberation so
liberation warrior is luffy obviously or
as some people believe joy boy's
reincarnation now it was implied last
chapter that luffy might have died and
joy boy might take over his body because
luffy's voice vanished but zunisha
seemed to finally hear joy boy's drums
of liberation after 800 years so luffy
disappears joy boy appears it seems to
suggest that but as you guys know i'd
hate that for luffy to lose his
personality even temporarily would suck
i'd prefer to think that the fruit
awakened and now luffy is fully luffy
but also fully joy boy keeping his same
personality in the spoilers we're told
some of luffy's allies including sanji
kid law hyogoro and marco feel luffy's
presence and that he is still alive so
this seems to answer that question that
this isn't just joy boy but is very much
our luffy as well i like how oda was
pretty tricky at the end of the last
chapter as he tends to be and i'm very
glad to see it turned out like this
because if an osutsuki just took over
luffy and beat the bad guy for him that
would not be very satisfying we are told
there is another conversation with the
five elders or gorosei and their
conversations are always hype we want
them to confirm why they want luffy so
bad since they did mention a fruit
that's had its name changed but they
didn't mention which fruit it was i
thought it was luffy's gomugomonomi from
the beginning and said as much of my
chapter reviews back then but it's nice
to see it finally confirmed here from
the horse's mouth they specifically say
the world government has always tried to
get the gomu gomu no me but they have
not been able to do it in 800 years we
know that they were pretty close when
shanks ended up taking it from them back
then a member says that the devil fruit
seems to run away from them and that he
is not crazy since the zone fruits have
a mind of their own a very interesting
comment first of all because it says
luffy doesn't have a paramecia but in
fact a zone which was one of my favorite
theories specifically the mythical zone
theory and furthermore a lot of people
have been talking about how fruits may
have their own wills recently and how
luffy's may have the will of joy boy in
it and that's how maybe joy boy could
take over and that's pretty much
confirmed to an extent here that having
a will of their own part although
interestingly enough they do specify
zone fruits a distinction that i didn't
hear anybody make since people often
cite how the fire logia made sabo act
more like ace when discussing this idea
oda might have purposely made that a red
herring but we'll see it does make more
sense to me for it to apply more to zone
fruits though especially to human human
fruits because humans are obviously more
associated with a will than elements
like fire or even animals which we
usually associate more with instinct
rather than free will and then the
elders say the gomu gomu nomi is
actually not only a zone type and not
only a human human type but they give us
the exact name the hitohito nomi aka
human human fruit mythological model
nika referencing the sun god again so
luffy does in fact have a mythical zone
based on this which is perfect for a
number of reasons a lot of people like
the resin theory but i was really hoping
against it since if the gomu gomu no me
had to be changed anyways we might as
well make it epic and i'm so glad it was
a mythical zone a sun god zone no less
this obviously means that we can expect
more fire powers like luffy's been
dabbling in and there's even images of
luffy's hair becoming fiery like nika's
silhouette which is perfect the eyebrows
are a little wacky for me but we'll see
how long this look lasts whether it's
like a super saiyan transformation and
luffy will be in base form most of the
time or whether it is a more or less
permanent thing i'd heavily assume that
the former rather than the latter is the
case though because we are used to
seeing luffy's base form and i can't see
them making such a big permanent change
and in the images it does seem like
luffy is laughing wildly which does seem
to be in direct contrast to when he was
very seriously trying to stop kaido asap
so at least some joy boy influence seems
to be coming through there and even
though he didn't have the monkey king
fruit all of this goes really well with
the journey to the west story that
inspired dragonball in one piece heavily
since the main character monkey who
shares luffy's name also ends up
experiencing his own awakening and
becomes a monkey god rather than just a
monkey king so my friends it seems like
luffy has overshot the target of pirate
king and become the pirate god one
that's so rare in fact the rarest since
this god hasn't appeared in 800 years
making him more significant than goldy
roger himself so after this insanity we
are told that we also see a part of
hiyori and orochi we'll have to wait for
the images to fully understand this one
so we'll come back to that when the full
translated pages are out but then now
here's the part that initially made me
doubt the spoilers because it seems too
good to be true and a lot of insane
stuff is happening all in one chapter
we're told luffy has awakened his fruit
and now he feels he is fully which
doesn't make a lot of sense but another
translation i saw from nerdsforlifeblog
on twitter says luffy has awakened his
fruit and now feels he's in his highest
peak and both translations say it's his
gear 5. so we can assume that what's
being said is that luffy feels he's at
his peak of power and that he's reached
his final form if you will since this is
a shonen i would never put a cap on
luffy's growth but at least he feels
he's stronger than he's ever been and
perhaps at his max potential as of now
absolutely crazy stuff including the
fact that we got gear 5 2 which of
course backs the idea that he'll turn
back to his base form after he's done
using it then as if this wasn't enough
for one chapter luffy aka joyboy reborn
fights kaido again luffy grabs kaido
from the roof and takes him upstairs and
then attacks him in a savage way bro
that scene i can totally picture and
it's gonna be insane imagine luffy's
hand expanding grabbing a yonko and
pulling him back up i don't know if it
will happen exactly like that but that
would be amazing and the savage part
really suggests we'll get to see luffy's
new power in action and how it may
differently impact kaido which i'm
really looking forward to then luffy
grabs the ground and transforms it into
rubber to return a bolo breath to kaido
this seemed over the top to me because
we already got awakening and gear 5 and
now we also got what many predicted
would be the rubber fruit awakening
being able to turn surrounding stuff
into rubber it's like oda put every
theory together and showed us in this
one chapter as luffy demolishes a yonko
although to be fair we don't know how
bad kaido will be heard from these
attacks but i assume it has to be
significantly more than before mythical
zone vs mythical zone i love it i also
love the fact that now just as magma was
above fire when akainu punched ace now
luffy's sun god powers should be above
magma when it comes to fights it
obviously depends a lot on how strong
the user is not just the fruit but i
like how luffy's fruit now has a similar
power to these two but it is obviously
superior too and it makes me excited for
luffy getting revenge against akainu we
are told there's no break next week
which is just insane i feel like if all
this was spread across three chapters
we'd still be satisfied we'd still be
hyped and it just happens in one chapter
chapter 1044 it is easily the best most
earth-shattering chapter of one piece
yet wow let me know your thoughts on
this are you as glad that luffy doesn't
have the resin fruit as i am and of
course luffy joy boy has got to be the
mvp for this chapter wow just insane
stuff i really can't put into words how
hyped this truly is if you did enjoy
this one piece video and want to keep
them coming you know what to do channel
the power king within and smash that
like button with no mercy remember
smashing that like button is pirate king
energy and passing is scared orochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my big and growing
one-piece playlist that includes videos
on all the yonko warlords supernova
admirals and much more linked to that is
in the description that's it look
forward to the whole official chapter
review later this week and until next
time see ya space cowboys